this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you all for coming and for this
opportunity to talk to you about what we
do in Geneva at the PGR you I have quite
a bit of material in my talk I try to
touch on a lot of different things
because there are a lot of different
things that we do and so I try to tell
you a little bit about everything so
I'll talk about the national plant
germplasm system and P GRU and what we
do at P GRU I'll also talk a little bit
about the green global database where
you can order germ plasm I get a lot of
questions about that and I'll talk a
little bit about the molecular research
that we've done and also about our
outreach activities so the MGP s it's a
cooperative effort by the state federal
in other organizations to preserve
genetic diversity and the idea is that
genetic uniformity increases
vulnerability to pass the stress and
disease so MGP s provides access to
genetic diversity so that breeders
researchers can bring forth new
varieties that can tolerate or resist
these diseases and stresses so we serve
science and education we acquire
preservative evaluate document and
distribute plant germplasm and this is
just to show you it is a national system
and spread throughout different drawing
regions so that for example the crops
that we have in Geneva New York are
things that do well in our temperate
climate as far as MPTs as of October
2017
there were over 15,000 species conserved
and over half of five hundred eighty
three thousand half-a-million accessions
in an accession you can think of as a
population it's a genetically unique
stock or population or clone of a tree
that is conserved as an entity so as far
as samples of seed or clones distributed
around a quarter of a million per year
throughout the whole system and about 30
percent of those are international and
that's just to show you that there are
29 repositories see crops Clara crops
genetic stocks and where are some of the
larger repositories and collections are
and that once that list on the side is
from the grand global database if
anybody ever wanted to look that up so
as far as in Geneva the secrets
repository we hold around 200 taxa in
over 12,000 accessions
and our major sea crops are listed here
onion celery different brassicas winter
squash buckwheat Tomatoes our largest
collection and radish in 2016 we
distributed close to 8000 samples of
seed and 254 orders and so I'll talk
about some of the activities when we
acquire germ plasm the purpose is to
fill gaps in our collections if people
go on collecting trips if those are
administered by the plant exchange
office in Maryland and they do
administer domestic and foreign plant
explorations and they review proposals
and I usually review some of these
proposals every year and rank them and
to support xe2 and institute
conservation of crop plants and wild
relatives for example for PGR you
the room was a collection in 2002 of
tomatillo and the former curator dr.
Robertson and dr. Todd vision from the
University North Carolina
did a joint collection and they
collected 111 accessions including some
large fruity types that we had never had
before and some self compatible types
that could be inbred which is unusual
for tomatillo in 2013 dr. song who is
also the research leader at PG are you
and dr. Robertson made a trip to the
Chinese Academy of Agricultural Sciences
in Beijing and they did some germplasm
exchange and I was telling done I was
supposed to fly to China tomorrow for a
similar opportunity but because Trump is
in China this week I can't go hopefully
it will happen at the end of the month
next month so for a regeneration is
quite a big project we do a couple
hundred plots usually on average 150 to
200 plots per year so each plot is a
population or accession and we cover
them with these nylon mesh cages when
they're ready to flower and then
honeybees are introduced we rent the
honeybees hives and we usually do about
eight different species or texta per
year including biennials and annuals and
we have different size cages depending
on the crops the winter squash go into
the largest cages they take up a lot of
space so this is just a some pictures of
the cages they have to be isolated from
each other so we use a plow to put soil
over the edges and then they have
zippers where you can go in and out of
the cage and we use black plastic to
grow everything except for the tomato
and then there's drip tape underneath
the plastic for the biennials they have
to be overwintered so for example other
cabbage or dug out of the fields they're
ready to do that now but it rains so
much we're not sure when we're gonna be
able to dig them but they go into these
wooden crates with sawdust and then
when they're planted you can see they're
just stubs in the field they take off
all the heads and they got that that
meristem the growing tissue tip there
and then those those are going to start
and then here you can see when they're
in the flowering stage there's a cage
around most people don't see cabbage
flowers because you eat the head and
that's a second year what happens and
those some things they might not flower
they might not have enough time so we
dig them up like these collards the
picture of the collards they were
brought in fertilized for like six or
eight weeks in a cold chamber in
December and then in January they flower
in the greenhouse and those are hand
pollinated so to pee on the crop we have
to sir custom regenerate it and then we
have we dry the material in mesh bags
that are hanging out at the barn and
then we have different types of machines
to Thresh the seed depending on the crop
and then for the seed storage um this
thing will come in from the barn and it
will go into this thing called the ante
room so the pre ante room is where we do
like seed orders it's controlled
humidity and temperature
you know we weigh the seed in there then
the ante room it's more like a
refrigerator and let me see
there's my pointer that's the ante room
here so we dry down the seed in that
room to six percent relative humidity
and that is stored long-term and then
this is the long-term storage facility
here so it's basically a freezer we do
characterize the time to characterize
for us is when we're regenerating so we
can only do highly heritable traits we
do collaborations with breeders and
other scientists if we get some grant
funding we could do more trace other
than just highly
haribol trace we can do things in
replicant for example in 2015 we did a
field trial of Brett of our Brassica
Rapa accessions
in collaboration with Michael Gore and
Chris Pearce um this year we start a new
way to collect data we bought this small
Android tablet it's very lightweight
easy and this field look freeware and
it's spreadsheet compatible so we can
collect data in a way that we can easily
upload it into the green global database
and I've been talking with Steph Taylor
at the Long Island regional sea
consortium about they are developing a
smartphone app that they'll share with
us so maybe hopefully I'll make it
easier for people that receive our
material to collect data for us that's
what they're aiming for and we did
collect data on six different crops this
summer and this is just a screenshot of
the field book giving the list of traits
um so the person who put this in she's
she put al best the crop so she put that
as a prefix to every trait so they was
all the traits would sort together by
crop because they're alphabetical so al
in this case is a liam and the BB is
biennial recipe and here's another
screenshot so it's a very nice interface
it's a very big interface so this is
plot for 10 like it was like a purse
economist tomato the tray is leaf type
and then you can see the definitions are
right there dwarf potato leaves etc so
she can just type in and number three
and then hit this one and it will scroll
to the next plot and then you can also
use photo as a tray it will collect the
photo and it will label the photo for
you with your plant ID which is nice so
we get images of plots of plants of hand
shapes as our traits and those go into
the green global database we do
um also scanning of fruits and this year
we tried to scan radish but it didn't
skin very well because it's so dark so
she ended up using a camera and they
don't look that nice I mean you have to
remember they were growing four seed
they weren't really grown for the radish
the edible portion but we've to give
people pictures is better than to not
give them pictures so we think it's
valuable to do these images and you can
see there's a lot of diversity in our
collection so I'm going to talk a little
bit about green global like I said I do
get quite a few questions about that and
it did change recently so this is if you
just googled green glow ball and PGS you
would get this is the starting page that
you would search from so if I suggest
that if you just like you're pretty sure
you're gonna order something the first
thing to do or maybe the second thing
after you found what you want but you
want to register with an account and
then read the Help section it's really
well written it's a good resource so you
can search for things like a descriptor
so in this case the descriptors are all
crop specific so I don't know how easy
it is for you to read this thing but
this is when you go to the descriptors
link you get the list of crops I picked
maize and then you get the traits for
maize coming up so I picked kernel color
you put a check mark and then you could
say equal to then I said red and then
you do the search and you ind Doug to
maize accessions with kernel color red
and then you would go through and check
the boxes of the ones that you want to
order and if you click on the name of it
you'll get a more detailed page and I'll
show you that in a minute there's
another way to order if you had a list
of accessions like pea I numbers usually
from a paper or something the search box
expands if you say using a list of
accessions and then you can just copy it
from a spreadsheet and paste it
here and get the search that way okay
this is what an accession page looks
like if you click on the accession this
is one P I of tomatillo you see the
image and there's also if it has it it
will have map data in there
it also has information here about its
source and things like that so if you
click on that map for this one the green
dot is that one accession and then these
other gods or other accessions and the
it's colored by a number of accession so
yellow is one accession and work session
so if you were trying to do a
geographical survey or study this would
help you to pick your material possibly
you can also use multiple criteria you
do advanced search and then in this case
you know there's a drop-down list of
things you can pick I pick two your
country of origin Brazil the state of
Rio de Janeiro and then for example you
could say improvement level is breeding
material and you can go on and on and
add multiple criteria one thing I really
like is the green taxonomy that's a
really good resource for anybody working
with plants um it gives the common names
it gives conspecific taxa and it gives
synonyms so if you're reading an old
paper and it's a genus and species and
you want to see what the current name is
it's a really good way to do that or
common names you know and you try to
look at the common name it's a very
scholarly set of information and it's
very well curated so there's a taxonomy
link there okay so now I'm gonna switch
to talk a little bit about some of the
genetic research that's going on in my
lab we've done quite a bit of genotyping
of collections and the method that we've
been using is genotyping by sequencing
and you've probably familiar with it
because a lot of the
was developed here at Cornell um it's
fairly inexpensive $20 per DNA sample
and if you do 96-well format on set of
samples and because you're finding your
mutations your markers your snips at the
same time that your genotyping them you
don't get the bias whereas if you just
had a set of markers and you use that
set to genotype your material you
wouldn't find the additional markers and
it doesn't require a reference genome
and that's really important for us
because with the exception of you know
tomato and the Brassica Rapa had a good
reference genome but some of the other
crops don't have any reference genome so
this is that same slide I showed you
earlier our major collections and what I
did was I just put an asterisk next to
the ones that we've done some GBS so
we've done most of the major collections
and I can't say we've done all the
accessions but we've done sampled
accessions and we pick the samples based
on certain criteria such as geography or
morphology so I'm going to go through
these just briefly to tell you the
highlights of these different studies so
the first one I'm talk about is I in
Allium CEPA it's highly consumed in the
United States its economic value its
ranks third amongst the vegetables
it's an ancient globally widespread crop
and there's thousands of onion cultivars
that have been developed to fit very
diverse environments and dietary
preferences it is a costly crop to breed
and conserve because it is biennial it
requires cross-pollination it's a very
daylight sensitive as far as whether or
not it will flower um also it has a very
large genome and so it's very hard to
develop molecular genetic markers that
breeders could you
when we did GBS we found 70,000 markers
single nucleotide polymorphism morphism
snip markers and we use doubled haploid
lines as controls those double tap legs
should be homozygous so whenever a
marker was not homozygous in one of
those th lines we threw it out and we
also had a mapping population f2 mapping
population that our collaborator my kV
had developed so we also use the
expected segregation ratios in that
population to decide whether markers
were high quality markers so you doing
this
we started with 70,000 we ended up with
900 markers um but those 900 markers
should be good high quality markers so
we concluded and we're going to write up
a paper what I have at the bottom here
is just a poster that gb/s is promising
I still have to analyze the data we have
95 of our accessions also genotyped but
I'll say it is promising but we had to
Jeff Club its who works here at Cornell
had to make custom scripts to analyze
the data because it was so challenging
with this large genome and I tried to
utilize it multiple times and I I just
didn't get very good results so with his
custom work and expertise we were able
to do it the next one I'll talk about is
Brassica Rapa it's different types of
Asian greens it's can be consumed raw or
cooked it's you might know it as mizuna
chinese cabbage bok choy a spice sarsen
it's also root vegetable turnip which is
also used as animal fodder and it's also
used as a cooking oil so these are all
different more four types that have been
developed you know across the globe but
the genetic relationship
haven't been well understood and if we
knew more about how they were related to
each other that would help breeders and
also conservation so we're able to
sample braska rep from our G Bank and
also from the gene bacon Ames Iowa and
we genotyped
ten different more four types and we
ended up with 333 accessions by over
18,000 snips and this was published this
year earlier Kevin BER was a student in
Chris Pierce lab and he took the lead on
this and published it and what he found
was that there was a genetic distinction
and among the more four types but also
the same more four type might be
genetically different if it had a
different geographic origin and so that
was the largest data set of this kind to
date the next one is tomatillo it
originated in central Mexico it's widely
cultivated in Guatemala and Mexico is
primarily concerned as relishes or
sauces such as green salsa and it's
becoming increasingly increasingly
important in the USA and then as a niche
crop it is considered underutilized
species by the FAO and breeders might be
interested in size disease resistance
and mechanical harvest previous studies
of populations showed them to be closely
related to each other that was worked by
todd vision who also went on that
collection trip with Larry um so we GBS
genotyped 125 accessions and we got a
pretty large data set um and basically
to summarize we did find a lack of
relationship based on geographical
origins similar to other researchers
have found but we did identify
eighty-six pairs of accessions that were
qualitatively different from each other
and we were able
to graphically represent qualitative
divergence among the 125 accessions and
we also confirm the homozygosity of the
have some new inbred lines that Larry
developed the next one we'll talk about
is wild tomato so this one a very
diverse wild tomato that's used a lot in
breeding solanum proved Yanam it was
recently reclassifying to four distinct
species but there is gene flow among the
species so we genotyped
forty six plants representing different
species about twelve perceives and found
and we used fourteen thousand of the
markers and we did find that based on
geography isolation by distance is the
geographical distance so that means they
we found support for isolation by
distances which means that things that
were sampled and more remote distances
from each other were more genetically
different from each other and especially
this pattern was observed if it was
between the pairs of species so that
supported some idea that there is
reproductive isolation between the
species and we found two of these new
taxa weren't significantly different
from each other genetically but we did
find a lot of markers that we could
possibly use as diagnostic markers to
identify the species and this is just a
graph of what I just mentioned that the
genetic distance is here and then the
log of the distances kilometers is here
and within a species the points are red
and between species the points are blue
so you can see there's a higher slope in
the blue one it was significant
so that's supporting that there is more
reproductive isolation isolation by
distance between species and within
species then I
I'll talk about quickly is a winter
squash it's been valued for its good
storage properties it has a thick hard
skin and it provides a wide range of
nutrients consumer demand has been
increasing very recent decades and it
has some naturally occurring compounds
that have been shown to have health
benefits and also use in pest control
improvement breeding is focused on fruit
size and shape non bitterness deep
orange fruit color earliness Bush habit
insect and disease resistance and what
we have are what we call course that's
based on morphological diversity
ninety-five of our accessions and
geographical diversity another 95
accessions from 38 countries but these
two sets overlap so there's a total of
165 accessions and we sampled plants
multiple plants per accession
right now we have the data collected and
I'm collaborating with people from cute
kept including some people from Cornell
and hopefully they have some data too so
we're going to put all of our data
together radishes the next one we'll
talk about it might not be that
important in the US but across the globe
it's pretty important it's 2% of all
global vegetable production it's
consumed as a root as a leafy vegetable
in some places as sprouts seeds or seed
pods and it's also used as a cover crop
or a forage crop Ouisa as a cover crop
it's nice it breaks up the soil and then
it provides organic material you know
for the soil to improve the soil it is
an ancient crop native to eastern
Mediterranean in eastern Asia and
there's some debate whether it's had
water and multiple domestication events
and there's a lot of morphological
diversity depending on where in the
globe it's utilized
there also adapts to local conditions
it's a rich source of nutrients so we
have of course that based on G a way to
geographical sampling that means we
sample more accessions if we had more
representation from that country so we
ended up with 35 countries 152
accessions and 5 plants per accession
and that data I haven't analyzed that's
one of the overlap interests with people
in China they're very interested they
study radish so hopefully our relations
and collaborations with them will move
this project forward um next one is
cultivate tomato like I said it's our
most important crop it's highly it's our
most important crop that we can serve
because we have the most successions and
we get the most requests for it it's
highly consumed in fresh and processed
forms it's considered a high value but
high risk crop because it is very
vulnerable to diseases mostly you
probably know that because you've tried
to grow some mostly well relatives are
used as breeding because it has a narrow
genetic base and it's like I said it's
very susceptible to pests and stresses
consumers in the US want more flavor
color they like the heirloom types but
those required still the resistances a
shelf-life and the durability so what we
have is 185 accession corset based on
geographical origin centers by diversity
fruit shape
heirlooms commercially important
varieties and we a say two sets of
96-well plates and when I analyze this
we ended up with around 3700 high
quality markers in 190 plants there's a
software you used to analyze what you
call the population
structure so we had Pimpernel Fillion is
a wild tomato' we have one sample of
that and what this is showing there's
like three virtual groups populations
the yellow the blue and the orange and
so what these numbers are across this
axis are the hundred ninety plants so
each of these little lines is that
genotype of that one plant so pimpernel
folium had the most yellow genome you
would call it virtual genome and then
also some of the blue but it didn't have
any of the orange so at this far end
genetically we had Pippen else William
at this far end way up here this sample
here was a pair type ellipsoid type
tomato from Italy it had a lot of the
orange a little blue and a little yellow
so what you're looking for is when I
point out here there's some kind of
genotypes that kind of stick out and
this is another way to look at it it's
called a neighbor joining tree is the
same data says the same data it's just
looking at in a different way it's more
like a tree so Pippen L folium is out
here you would expect so this is the
most distantly related to all these
other genotypes the branches length of
the tree is the genetic distance and
then what you're seeing are a lot of
things that kind of just are closely
related but then you see these outliers
so these Italian types look diverged
there's this cherry tomato type here
this divergent and then you get these
other accessions that are also divergent
and they're kind of falling more towards
Pimpernel folium so what those are are
probably land races that might have
crossed with Pimpernel folium in their
history so what we have here this is a
land race accession this closely related
to well tomato yet it has this big large
red fruit so I guess
we found is there could be some
exceptions in our collection that could
have diverse genes but they still have
the large red round fruit which pimping
Ella phillium has a small small fruit
that tastes terrible
so if a breeder wanted to try to get
something that was divergent but not go
for that little tiny terrible fruit they
might try to use something like this
yeah so we're winding down here so the
other thing I just want to mention it
was some of our outreach in education
activities we rarely ever say no if
somebody asks us to do outreach we try
to accommodate them and one of our most
popular things that we get invited for
is to extract DNA from a banana using
common household chemicals and I show
over here what we use and this is um an
elementary school in Geneva it's called
science night and you can see the kids
come and they get to do it hands-on and
then they get to see the DNA we use a
toothpick and they can pull the DNA out
of the solution they take the DNA home
if they want to allow them do and they
really love it and they and we give them
the protocol so they can take it home
and teach other people how to do it so
let's just try to educate you know the
public about what DNA is another thing
that I'm pretty heavily involved in is
called the northern organic vegetable
improvement collaborative know that and
people Cornell are also involved in this
like Michael Missouri right now but
Molly John was the one that kind of
started it many years ago it wasn't
under the same name but it's the same
project that's evolved over time the
idea is to breed new varieties for
organic condition that do well in
northern climates so they try to
identify the best varieties for organic
firms they work directly with farmers
educate others
and exceeds variety trials and I'm fart
breeding and what we do mostly because
we're so good at sue cleaning we teach
people about saving seed and how to
process see how to grow things to save
the seed so this is these are pictures
from a fair that we do in Maine every
year where we actually bring up a
trailer full of heart-like threshers and
the wetsy processor for the tomato and
we get a lot of people coming to try
learn how to do these things and we hand
out a lot of information and we hand out
seeds also that brings people so I'm
gonna wrap it up now I just thank you
all for your patience and for being here
we have a big staff that work I work
with every day and they make all this
possible it ranges from greenhouse to
farm to the seed storage the database
person and then Susan does research
support like the field characterization
and a lab characterization and we have a
lot of technical assistance on these
three individuals just graduated from
Hobart away Smith Colleges last spring
and then they came out to work with us
temporarily and learn a lot about
agriculture and that's a picture of me
and Larry Robertson our farmer curator
I'm AG McGrath's in Long Island tomato
trials a few years ago they have such
sandy soil down there we could use a
golf cart and that was really great we
really enjoyed that so I'll be happy to
take any questions and thank you yeah
Geneva are you there do you have any
questions
that was a Louisville talk thank you so
much
I was curious with your Allium diversity
study it looked like you really had to
libel down the good snips to what seven
or nine hundred forget the exact number
yeah yeah that's true yep you're really
wacky segregation distortion that he saw
in that population and I know it's a lot
of it has to do with probably tandem
duplications yeah so like I said I
wasn't able to analyze it every when I
did get a set of snips and then I would
give them to our collaborator my kV to
map them he found that they were
clustering together they weren't really
well distributed either so like I said
Jeff had to really do a lot of extra
custom scripts to analyze the data to
get down to those 900 thank you so much
yep thanks sequencing information
collection that breeders might use I'm
curious like what you think from a
conservation standpoint the implication
yeah um I know there's different ideas
about that um kind of we don't want to
get rid of things and say we have this
course that represents all the diversity
we don't need the rest of the collection
that's not something that I I would be
in favor or mpg-us doesn't have that
philosophy it's nice to have what you
call a course at a lot of times I don't
even like to call the course that I'd
like to call a diversity panel based on
whatever it was
developed you know geography or
morphology but I imagine there is a lot
of redundancy you know we know there's
probably a lot of redundancy we can't
conserve all of it it would just cost
too much but for something like tomato
the life of those seeds is fifty or a
hundred years the way we store them so
we can't afford to keep them until
somebody can sequence the whole genome I
don't think it'll be that long before
it'll be we're affordable to sequence
the whole genome a multiple plans for
accession you know what what makes a
high quality yeah yeah that's a good
question it goes through a analysis
pipeline so things that you look at how
many times is it observed you know you
have millions of sequences so you know
how many times is observed and there's
gonna be a threshold you set you set
these parameters depending on your
sample size in the biology for example
for the mapping population they need to
be in the parents right we don't want
anything that wasn't in the parents and
that mapping population and they had to
segregate the way they were expected and
they had to be homozygous so those are
the male's the other thing is you only
want we don't want more than two alleles
at a locus these are mutations in the
DNA so you're not likely going to get
three mutations it's going to be an
alignment problem with the sequence that
gave you that third or fourth mutation
you know if you have GATC you just want
two of those you do want three or four
of those because that's probably
alignment misalignment maybe there was
an insertion or deletion nearby that
caused it to look like a mutation so
those are the those are some of the
things that you you set the parameters
in
pipeline filter we call it filtering
them down so Joanne spoke about putting
seeds into the deep freeze for long-term
storage do you periodically retest the
viability of that see yes so they're
tested before they go into storage
they're tested so the things that just
came out of the field in 2017 after
they're given a few weeks to dry down
then they'll be viability tested if they
don't have good viability we won't
probably keep them unless it's the only
thing we have then we would keep it but
yeah they should undergo if depending on
the crop every 5 or 10 years and that's
the kind of thing if we could get more
feedback from people that we send it to
we wouldn't necessarily have to do that
germ cast ourselves we could use their
data like if we send somebody 50 seeds
and they say oh they're great
we got 100 percent sure we would use
that you know observation so yeah we do
some of our own germ testing and we're
also outsource some of it self
incompatible yeah that's why we use the
honey bees in the cages or we do it by
hand so the accession is a diverse
population so you don't have within that
accession it's not incompatible with
itself but yeah
do out cross them if we if if we have to
do it by hand with a paintbrush we do it
by hand but then they're gonna cross to
other plants in the same accession like
radish for example did that answer yeah
we don't have like breeding what we
don't have a lot of like highly inbred
material or highly inbred stocks or
things or mutant stocks or things like
that we don't generally have that time
material we have populations this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at Cornell edu